[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime-doku von
Bild
hallo zusammen und schön dass ihr bei
einer neuen Folge von Tatort Deutschland
mit dabei seid ich bin Toni und ich bin
Mirco und wir haben gleich zu Beginn
eine ganz wichtige Bitte an euch diese
Podcast ist für euch wie immer kostenlos
aber ihr könnt uns natürlich trotzdem
unterstützen wenn ihr uns folgt indem er
die Glocke aktiviert und da wo ihr uns
hört eine gute Bewertung hinterlasst
vielen Dank dafür
unser heutiger Fall ist nicht nur die
Geschichte eines furchtbaren Mordes
sondern auch ein Justiz Krimi der Mörder
ist bekannt aber er konnte in den ersten
Anläufen nicht verurteilt werden wegen
unseres heutigen falls wurden sogar die
Gesetze geändert er hat buchstäblich
Schlagzeug gemacht und von den lesen wir
mal einige vor
während Sammler findet Leiche bei Zelle
wer tötete die 17-jährige Friederike sie
wurde 1981 vergewaltigt unterstochen
Friederike ist Mörder ist überführt aber
frei
Bundesverfassungsgericht berät
Grundsatzfrage wird Friederikes Mörder
erneut angeklagt
er kämpfte die Neuauflage Hans von
Möhlmann stirbt kurz vor dem Prozess bei
der Bild-Zeitung kümmert sich seit
Jahren Lena Zander um diesen Fall
sie kommt in dieser Folge mehrfach zu
Wort und führt uns jetzt erstmal zum
Anfang des Geschehens am Abend des 4
november 1981
Friederike war am 4 november 1981 in
Celle bei einer Chorprobe und bei der
Bus schon weg war und niemand sie
abholen konnte ist sie zu einem Fremden
ins Auto gestiegen das hat Friederike
schon häufiger gemacht dass trampen war
damals nicht außergewöhnliches für das
Mädchen allerdings ist sie zu dem
falschen ins Auto gestiegen der Mann
fuhr mit ihr in einen Waldstück
vergewaltigte sie und stach sie mit dem
Messer nieder der hat ihr wirklich die
Kehle durchtrennt danach hatte das
Mädchen dort liegen lassen und es
geflüchtet mit seinem Wagen
Friederike ist 17 Jahre alt hat
mittellange dunkle Haare sehr wache
Augen und ein hintergründiges
humorvolles lächeln sie wohnt in der
10.000 Einwohner Stadt Hambühren und
geht in Celle auf das Kaiserin Auguste
viktoria-gymnasium das ist rund 8 km von
zu Hause entfernt
verglichen mit anderen Mordfällen ist
das schreckliche Verbrechen an
Friederike relativ schnell aufgeklärt
die Spurensicherung Werte Textilfasern
an der Leiche des Mädchens aus und
kümmert sich um die Reifenspuren auf dem
Gelände am Straßenrand es hat sich
relativ schnell abgezeichnet dass ismeth
H ein Kurde stämmiger Einwanderer als
hauptverdächtig gilt der wurde auch vor
Gericht gestellt und 1982 vom
Landgericht Lüneburg zu lebenslange Haft
wegen Mordes verurteilt das ganze ging
dann in die nächste Instanz und das
Urteil wurde aufgehoben wenig später
durch das Landgericht Stade bei den
haben die Indizien die es damals gegeben
hat nicht gereicht die Indizien auf die
sich das Gericht bei der ersten
Verurteilung gestützt hat waren
Faserspuren in seinem Auto der hatte
Teppich in seinem Auto liegen und
ähnliche Faserspuren hat man auch an der
Kleidung von Friederike gefunden
außerdem gab es einen Reifen Gutachten
die haben Reifen Spuren genommen in dem
Waldstück und verglichen mit den Reifen
das mutmaßlichen Täters und haben
festgestellt dort gibt es eine
Übereinstimmung alles nur Indizien keine
handfesten Beweise in den 80er Jahren
Frederikes Vater ihre Mutter und die ein
Jahr ältere Schwester Susann müssen sich
also nicht nur damit abfinden dass das
Mädchen nie zurückkommt sondern auch
damit dass der Mörder frei herumläuft
Friederikes Vater Hans von Müllmann der
schwört sich immer weiter für
Gerechtigkeit zu kämpfen aber erst mehr
als 30 Jahre nach dem Mord kommt die
Gelegenheit es ist wie schon in anderen
Fällen die wir hier hatten der
Fortschritt bei der DNA-Analyse der den
Durchbruch bringt wenn ihr die
Geschichte von Sigrid C bei Tatort
Deutschland noch nicht gehört habt ihr
findet die Folge die Spur unter dem
Fingernagel bei den Uploads anfangen Mai
und auch im Fall Friederike von Müllmann
bringt das Erbgut des Täters den Fall
noch mal vor Gericht
2012 kann Hans von Müllmann durchsetzen
das Spuren an Frederikes Kleidung mit
der DNA von Ismet h abgeglichen werden
und es gibt einen Treffer
der Verdächtige von damals ist auch
jetzt wieder der mutmaßliche Schuldige
das war vor elf Jahren und noch immer
sorgt die Geschichte für Gesprächsstoff
nochmal Lena Zander dazu wir reden jetzt
quasi noch drüber weil dieser Fall etwas
ganz Besonderes ist sowas hat es in
Deutschland noch nicht gegeben dieser
Fall schreibt wirklich Rechtsgeschichte
denn gerade war die Verhandlung die
mündliche Verhandlung vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe wo
ist um eine Gesetzesänderung ging denn
Friederike von Müll meines Vater hat
nicht aufgegeben der hat wirklich er
sich zu Lebensaufgabe gemacht zu kämpfen
und den Mörder seiner Tochter zu finden
und 2012 hat er es geschafft dass eine
DNA-Analyse in Auftrag gegeben wurde und
diese DNA-Analyse zeigte die Sperma
Spuren die in Friederike Slip gefunden
wurden die Stimmen mit Ismet h überein
in Deutschland ist es allerdings so
gewesen zu dem Zeitpunkt dass niemand
wegen derselben Straftat zweimal
angeklagt werden darf also hatte er
eigentlich den Beweis dass ismetall der
Mörder seiner Tochter ist aber konnte
nichts tun der Durchbruch von 2012
bringt also immer noch keine
Gerechtigkeit aber Hans von Müllmann
macht einfach weiter
2015 haben Friederikes Vater und sein
Anwalt Wolfgang Schädler sich einen
Trick zu eigen gemacht und zwar sind sie
vor Zivilgericht gezogen und haben
ismetall auf Schmerzensgeld verklagt
für die psychischen Schäden die Hans
Mühlmann erlitten hat durch die
Vergewaltigung und den Tod seiner
Tochter das Gericht hat die Klage
abgewiesen bei der Anspruch verjährt es
aber in seiner Urteilsbegründung hat das
Gericht etwas ganz Besonderes
geschrieben und das würde ich gerne
einmal vorlesen und zwar schrieb das
Gericht
der Beklagte vergewaltigte und tötete
anschließend die Tochter des Klägers
also hatte Hans von Müllmann ist schwarz
auf weiß East methar ist der Mörder
seiner Tochter aber damit konnte er
immer noch nichts machen weil das Gesetz
in Deutschland immer noch Bestand hatte
Hans von Mühlmann hat aber nicht
aufgegeben er hat eine Online-Petition
gestartet und 180.000 Stimmen für eine
Gesetzesänderung gesammelt und
schließlich hat er damit auch Erfolg im
Dezember 21 ist dieses neue Gesetz auch
in Kraft getreten
ismetha kam wieder ein Untersuchungshaft
der Prozess war schon angesetzt für
Sommer 22 dann haben seine Anwälte
allerdings Verfassungsbeschwerde
eingelegt und diese
Verfassungsbeschwerde wurde gerade vor
dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht in Karlsruhe
verhandelt da fand gerade die mündliche
Verhandlung statt da wird jetzt
abgewogen ob dieser wirklich 2000 Jahre
alte Grundsatz das niemand wegen einer
Straftat zweimal angeklagt werden darf
aufgehoben wird oder nicht und so lange
es diesmal wieder auf einem Fuß es war
unter polizeilichen Auflagen er muss
sich zweimal die Woche bei der Polizei
melden er musste seinen Ausweis abgeben
aber er lebt weiter sein Leben Hans von
Müllmann hat es also geschafft über
100.000 Unterschriften für
Gesetzesänderung zu sammeln damit der
Mörder seiner Tochter verurteilt werden
kann er hat es geschafft dass das Gesetz
tatsächlich geändert wurde im Bundestag
und gerade erst vor ein paar Tagen hat
das Bundesverfassungsgericht offiziell
den Einspruch gegen diese Änderung
entgegengenommen was für ein justizkrimi
der SPD Rechtsexperte Johannes Fechner
erläutert dies im Talk viertel nach acht
bei Bild so da geht es um die Frage ob
ein Gesetz dass wir geschaffen haben
2021 Bestand haben wird ob es
verfassungswesen ist oder nicht wir
haben gesagt wenn einem Mörder die Tat
nachgewiesen werden kann nachdem er
schon freigesprochen wurde dann wäre es
Schreien des Unrecht wenn er will diesen
Nachweis nicht verurteilt werden kann
und da sind wir gespannt ob das
Bundesverfassungsgericht uns recht gibt
oder ob das fassungsgericht den Gegnern
zuneigt die behaupten wenn einmal eine
Entscheidung gefallen ist dann muss sie
erst Rechtssicherheitsgründen bestehen
wir meinen es wäre scheint es Unrecht
Männer nicht für euch werden nur einer
bekommt all das tragischerweise nicht
mehr mit es ist Friederikes Vater Angst
von Müllmann ist im Sommer letzten
Jahres gestorben das heißt er kann all
das nicht mehr miterleben als der starb
saß der mutmaßliche Mörder seiner
Tochter
jetzt hat Friederike Schwester Susanne
die Nebenklage übernommen und das heißt
der Anwalt Wolfram Schädler konnte
weitermachen und diese Klage auch weiter
fortführen
und das andere besonders schlimme was
die Familie extrem verletzt ist dass
ismetall kurz nach seinem Freispruch
selbst geheiratet hat selbst Kinder
bekommen hat inzwischen auch Enkelkinder
hat er lebt in einer niedersächsischen
kleinen Stadt hat hatte dort drei Häuser
die er vor kurzem auf seine Kinder
überschrieben hat und lebt wirklich
Tür an Tür mit seinen Liebsten während
Frederikes Familie ihre Liebste
Friederike auf grausamste Art und Weise
verloren hat das ist also ein Fall bei
dem es jederzeit Neuigkeiten geben kann
und sobald sich etwas tut bei der
Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts holen wir uns
Lena ins Studio und berichten euch wie
es weitergeht und das war's für heute
wir hoffen ihr seid doch beim nächsten
Mal wieder dabei ganz herzliche Dank
geht heute unsere Reporterin alsander
euer Mirko und eure tun